bueno el candidato Ciro Gómez es un
candidato de Centro izquierda pero que y
la izquierda del partido de los
trabajadores intentó presionarlo para
que desistiera de su candidatura Así que
se enojó mucho con el partido de los
trabajadores y en los debates
centraba sus acusaciones todas embolsona
en nula
centrado sus acusaciones todas en nula
aunque fuera también de izquierda
sin embargo creo que sus electores son
electores que quizás sean de Centro ahí
y un quizás un poco más a la izquierda
pero es gente que
ya no quiere más al partido de los
trabajadores y en el en la primera
vuelta quiso dar un voto
en lo que realmente cree en lugar de dar
su voto útil a Lula entonces puede ser
que ese voto del candidato de Centro
izquierda Ciro Gómez se transfieran a
Lula
Bueno sobre todo en los estados del
norte en relación
porque es bonita es una calidad de
Centro derecha
pertenece al mismo partido del ex
presidente Michelle temer es un partido
tradicional uno de los más antiguos del
país que conforma el centro de
legislativo
se salió muy bien todos los debates la
mayoría de los analistas las
consideraron las que mejor se salió en
todos los debates presidenciales que Se
realizaron en las cadenas públicas de
televisión y quizás sus votos sean mitad
una mitad vas a transferirse a Lula y
una otra mitad a bol